sophie mongeon qui est avocate
spécialisée en droit administratif et en
droit du travail bon soir en soir est ce
que le premier ministre a raison de dire
que les employeurs ont le droit d'exiger
la vaccination départ de leurs
travailleurs c'est une excellente
question monsieur fillion mais là encore
je pense que parfois on cherche une
réponse toute cuite tout de suite il une
solution à toutes les situations mais
encore le droit du travail c'est
toujours des questions individuelles et
je pense que ça dépend encore du domaine
de travail il sait quoi le titre de
l'emploi alors ça vaut rester encore du
cas pourquoi pour les prochains temps
selon moi ok même si le premier ministre
dit cela il permet de nuancer ce que
vous dites qu'il faut apporter
cela dit rendu au 2 septembre 2021 après
dix-huit mois de pandémie est ce que
travailleur peut encore dire je refuse
d'être vaccinés à son employeur je pense
que maintenant pour invoquer un refus
fouquet une raison valable pour que ce
soit au delà d'un simple caprice parce
que sinon les droits collectifs on voit
clairement pris le dessus sur les droits
individuels bien qu'on a le droit selon
la charte québécoise de décider pour soi
même il ya toujours des exceptions qui
sont prévues même dans la charte ou un
employeur peut si c'est une exigence
professionnelle justicier demander quand
même ce genre d'éléments la sks qu'un
travailleur a quand même des arguments
potentiel pour pour venir compte
contester l'obligation vaccinale de son
employeur oui il pourrait évoquer par
exemple des droits de santé ça c'est une
excuse valable une justification
j'avais pensé à certains moment donné
que peut-être évoqué la religion aussi
court être une justification mais
éventuellement le regardait un peu tout
et partout qu' aucune religion et contre
la vaccination donc actuellement une des
seules raisons valables ce serait
effectivement une question médicale une
question médicale donc une personne qui
dit j'ai fait des recherches
je n'ai pas assez d'information je
préfère attendre tout ça est allé vite
ce n'est pas une excuse valable
effectivement la ce moment là s'il dit
pour une raison x y z qui ne veut pas
être vaccinés à ce moment là il pourrait
demander une un accommodement
raisonnable mais auxerre très heureux
parce que l'empereur lui pour invoquer
qu'au contraire c'est une contrainte
excessive c'est pas juste pour les
autres pour les autres employés donc ça
porte atteinte à la sécurité des
employés et des usagers est aussi
s'avérer un coût et un fardeau trop
important pour l'avoir de restructurer
donc dans la mesure où le commandement
qu'on demande devient trop excessive à
ce moment là il pourrait avoir des
conséquences
et là effectivement l'employeur pourrait
cv jonchent encore jeudi demain monsieur
fillion mieux doté et à la mise à pied
temporaire
il ya d'autres gens vous avant le
châtiment finale du congédiement le
châtiment finale est ce que ces
châtiments final ce congédiement
pourrait même être légale si quelqu'un
se fait congédier parce qu'il ne veut
pas se faire vacciner pour revenir au
travail c'est légal de faire ça mais
pour l'instant je peux répondre à cette
question là parce qu' aucune décision le
aucun tribunal à trancher encore sur
cette question la sq aussi c'est que des
décisions qui ont été rendus sur
d'autres aspects d'autres mesures qui
avaient été prises au niveau de la
pandémie par exemple le tribunal
d'arbitrage viendront une décision tout
laisse à mahler ou où ils ont maintenu
la suspension de cap - qu'un salarié
avait eu pour avoir refusé de se laver
les mains à l'entrée c'est une
obligation d'une compagnie
manufacturière à l'époque qu'ils
écoutent pour rentrer vos petites lovely
mail le trader avait refusé pour des
raisons qui ont été jugé non valable et
tribunal et bondir de l'employeur à des
suspendus à juste raison le travailleur
pour quatre mois sans salaire donc on
voit que la jurisprudence pour l'instant
qui statue sur des mesures que défaite
en début de pandémie ne sont pas très
très positif pour le travailleur est ce
que l'on est ce que plusieurs autres
comme ça ah oui je note qu effectivement
qui est différente mais on a une
compagnie de
une technicienne ambulancière par
exemple qui elle avait tu es est obligé
d'être en isolement pendant trois jours
et elle demandait d'être indemnisés par
le travailleur par l'employeur l'emploi
avait refusé le syndicat a fait un
lierre et larbi ben m'hidi que
l'empereur n'était pas obligé de payer
cette personne là pendant les trois
jours d'isolement parce que c'était pas
priver la convention collective et
c'était beau indiquer dans un arrêté
ministériel
est ce que vous verrez que les
travailleurs n'ont finalement
aujourd'hui parce que plus de défense
face aux exigences vaccinale qui
pourrait venir des employeurs ça
commençait très difficile là si on fait
une comparaison par exemple avec un
jugement qui a été rendu à la cour
suprême illinois si je me trompe pas où
il ya des étudiants qui avaient fait une
contestation sur la politique de
l'université qui exigeait que toutes
leurs étudiants sous à vacciner eux lyon
évoqué que ça allait à l'encontre de
leurs droits et ses îles la cour suprême
ait voulu dire non les droits collectifs
crime au delà des droits individuels la
jurisprudence est pas vraiment d'humeur
des travailleurs pour l'instant m ce
film aux gens c'est très intéressant où
vous êtes spécialisé en droit du travail
c'est c'était le bon moment de faire
cette entrevue je pense merci beaucoup
merci au revoir nos émissions en entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et redit